diez meses después de la reconciliación
diplomática en abril del año pasado
llega a esta reunión de alto nivel entre
España y Marruecos que inició con un
foro económico en el que el presidente
del gobierno de Marruecos así seanus
tildó de Valiente el apoyo de España el
plan de autonomía marroquí para el
Sáhara occidental un cambio de postura
histórico en marzo de 2022 que puso fin
a meses de crisis entre ambos países
crisis que rabat calificó de
malentendido para Marruecos esto es una
oportunidad de abrir el comercio español
hacia África a través de la nación
magrebí a donde llega el 50% de las
exportaciones que hace España al
continente también por otro lado para
abrirse al mercado latinoamericano a
través de España si el comercio hoy fue
el aperitivo mañana se sirve el plató
fuerte con la reunión bilateral entre
Pedro Sánchez ysagnus y la firma de más
de 20 acuerdos los temas varían mucho
desde las energías renovables a la
seguridad o el control migratorio
por último es utilizado como moneda de
cambio por Marruecos para conseguir
avances en su agenda política el
gobierno español ha asegurado que esta
reunión de alto nivel que no se
celebraba desde 2015 es crucial para la
relación no solo entre rabat y Madrid
sino con la Unión Europea una relación
es que están a la baja tras el escándalo
de corrupción del qatargate en el que
Marruecos está involucrado y la
resolución del parlamento europeo
pidiendo respeto a la libertad de prensa
en el país magrebí una resolución a la
que se opusieron los eurodiputados
socialistas españoles junto con la
ultraderecha francesa